all right let's go to our caller from
the 8:01 area code who's calling today
from eight zero one David does that mean
that is you who's this this is Ethan
from Provo Utah hey Ethan also on a
second Tommy from DC's thoughts on razor
fist that debate was another nail in the
coffin for any libertarian beliefs ahead
so shoutout to Calculon ski I'll have to
check that out yeah it was he got a
piledriver as they say but anyway David
there's a question I have this is like
kind of going on in Utah politics I
don't know if you've heard so the last
election we had a proposition - that was
a you know Utah's first medical
marijuana bill and right and it passed
and since then like the legislature
stepped in and I don't know how much
Utah politics you know but there's an
insane Mormon influence yes that I know
and a lot of I mean like look at Mitt
Romney so I mean that's I think Mike Lee
as well I mean you know so they're all
in bed with the church and they and the
church is like at the table on any sort
of legislative issue that we got going
on it's pretty insane and so since the
proposition to pass the legislators have
been like oh we're gonna like we're
going to rewrite it because it's like
not good enough and they wanted it to be
like only pharmacists can hand out
medical marijuana but like pharmacists
can't do that because it's still illegal
no federally I don't know it's it's just
a it's just kind of annoying here David
like being a citizen because they also
are doing this with the Medicaid
expansion like we'll vote on something
that's like let us change it like I like
yeah well listen I mean I I don't envy
you in the sense that I'm not looking to
move to Utah
anytime soon but is there anything
specific you wanted me to address today
um yeah so like I guess the the question
I have I hope this doesn't sound like
I'm just venting
but it's like like what are we supposed
to do as you know like what am I
supposed to do as a citizen we when we
get together as a state and like vote on
something and the legislators just like
just kind of drag their asses you got to
work the grassroots I mean this is what
Republicans are so good at if they fill
state legislatures with people that
think exactly the way you're describing
which you don't like and we just have to
be as good as they are at the ground
game and we're not that's just the
reality whether it's within or outside
of the Democratic Party and some of you
know local races the partisan side is
less important than the ideological side
we've got to start building up that
grassroots local local election movement
listen I got a run but I appreciate the
call and bet sounds like Utah's dealing
with some serious stuff there I've never
been but I may be going sort of soon for
a wedding that is not a Mormon wedding
interestingly enough okay that's it for
today sorry I know there were people I
was not able to get to but I will be
streaming soon and it will be another
opportunity to take some more calls